that's holding up hanging in there oh
god she's doing better than me yeah um
I'm like I don't I think I'm so in shock
and um the kids are keeping me busy so
you had a baby five weeks ago yes so and
she came early said yeah she came three
weeks early
her mom got to meet her yes thank God
what was that moment like it was nice
you know
I even think what happened to my mother
wasn't happen so you know I wasn't even
thinking along those lines
what were those final final days like in
the hospital for her she wanted to go
home that's what she said I could just
picture her right now making jokes the
hospital even at that time in her yeah
she was just uh you know right before
she died you know went that's the
hospital you know we were cooking for ha
you know um and she said I gotta get
sick more often cuz I love this you know
she had her son to you myself to the end
so that she's no dancer what I'm I had
to take it to the bedroom because she
couldn't really walk and she decided to
hum a song and be like this and dance I
had to hold her up but she was dancing
who was with her when she passed away
we're wrong everybody who wasn't that 60
people in aa so I think that it was just
a moment of like serenity at that time
when she finally took her last breath
because we had like we were like
laughing about something and it was just
very peaceful and there was like no
crying going on and that's when she went
like she wanted us to all be that state
I think of justice you know peace and
accepting this for what it was and but
she was she was accepting of it yeah the
week before when she was in the hospital
she told the doctor like I'm not I'm
okay to die like I lived my life and my
kids have their families now and
you know my kids grow up without a
grandmother and you know we would be
okay
you